queridas
hermanas y hermanos
pueblo hondureño
la presidencia de la república
nunca ha sido asumida por una mujer en
honduras
han tenido que pasar
200 años
desde que se proclamó
nuestra independencia
estamos
estamos rompiendo cadenas
y estamos rompiendo tradiciones
este hecho histórico
solo pudo surgir de la voluntad
mayoritaria del pueblo
gracias pueblo hondureño
[Aplausos]
gracias
por este honor y confianza
este día histórico
informaré a la nación y a nivel
internacional
sobre las cifras reales
no maquilladas
de lo que estoy recibiendo
sobre la tragedia social
y económica que enfrenta honduras
y sobre mi propuesta de refundación
del estado socialista y democrático
[Aplausos]
el estado de honduras
ha sido hundido estos últimos 12 años
y lo recibo en bancarrota
el país
debe de saber
qué hicieron con el dinero
[Aplausos]
y dónde están los
20 millones de dólares
que sacaron en préstamos
mi gobierno
no continuará a la vorágine de saqueo
que ha condenado a las generaciones de
jóvenes
a pagar la deuda que contrajeron a sus
espaldas
debemos arrancar de raíz la corrupción
de los 12 años de dictadura
[Aplausos]
tenemos
el derecho de refundar nos sobre valores
soberanos
no sobre la usura y el agiotaje
la catástrofe económica que recibo
no tiene parangón en la historia del
país
y su impacto en la vida de la gente se
refleja por el aumento de 700 por ciento
de la deuda
la pobreza se incrementó al 74 por
ciento
para convertirnos en
el país más pobre de américa latina'
esta cifra por sí misma
explica la caravana de miles de personas
que de todas las edades
huyen para el norte
méxico y eeuu
buscando un lugar y una forma de
subsistir sin importar el riesgo para
sus vidas
el estado fue constituido para asegurar
a sus habitantes el goce de la justicia
la libertad la cultura y el bienestar
económico y social
y como consecuencia
tenemos el deber de registrar o
restaurar el sistema económico
sobre la base de la transparencia
la eficiencia de la producción
y justicia social en la distribución de
la riqueza y el ingreso nacional
a pesar de los groseros impuestos que
nos han asestado
y el aumento de ingresos tributarios
durante el periodo de 2009 al 2022
ha sido tan alto el endeudamiento el
pago de los intereses
y el pago del capital
que en este momento consume el 50 por
ciento de los ingresos del presupuesto
general de la república
después de 12 años de dictadura
subió el saldo de la deuda interna
de 20 mil millones
a
179 mil millones
700 por ciento
el saldo de la deuda externa
de 37 mil millones
subió a
157 mil millones
319 por ciento
con estas cifras
es evidente que el estado no tiene
capacidad para sostener
la estruendosa y bochornosa deuda que
nos están heredando
prácticamente imposible cumplir con los
vencimientos de la deuda
la única forma
es un proceso de
reestructuración integral mediante a un
acuerdo con los acreedores privados y
públicos
hablando del presupuesto
se desglosa en
38 mil líneas
y comprenden
393 objetos objetos de gasto para 101
instituciones
la mayor parte del presupuesto
se destina a sueldos y salarios
a sueldos y salarios
de los 210 mil empleados públicos
ciento cincuenta y dos mil
trabajan en la secretaría de salud
educación
defensa y seguridad
el decreto legislativo
que publicó la dictadura aprobando un
presupuesto para mi administración
violando el principio de la no
intervención en el siguiente gobierno
comprende
solo los montos globales y las
disposiciones legales a aplicar pero no
nos proporcionaron el detalle por objeto
de gasto
ninguna garantía de los ingresos para
financiarlo
la pregunta
que todos los hondureños nos hacemos
este presupuesto
cuánto dinero
llega a la gente pobre
al servicio de a quién está el
presupuesto
quién audita el presupuesto y su
ejecución
qué hacen
con la corrupción presupuestaria
porque disponer de recursos económicos
para la inversión en la gente es uno de
mis fundamentales misiones en mi mandato
el eje transversal
del próximo presupuesto que enviaré al
congreso nacional
será de
transparencia
y al anticorrupción
ahora
daré algunos datos sobre la empresa
nacional de energía eléctrica
la destrucción de la enee
es una mancha que nos deja la dictadura
y un agujero fiscal de dimensiones
insalvables a corto plazo
el problema
va más allá de lo energético
es un problema social
económico y con un proceso potencial
que incentiva la migración
las opciones que me han presentado
los organismos financieros
es contratar más deuda
no para salvar a la n
sino para salvar a los proveedores de la
enee
con tratar
más deuda
para el pago de los generadores de
energía
sin un programa de emergencia energética
equivale a convertirse en cómplice de la
usura y el agiotaje
legalizados con contratos lesivos al
interés nacional
aprobaron leyes
para sacar satisfacer intereses creados
organizaron la secretaría de energía
y el centro de despacho donde los
representantes son nombrados por los que
venden la energía
es decir
son juez y parte
en el df y en el cree
partieron
en tres pedazos la n
y dieron la administración en tres
fideicomisos
otorgaron un contrato oneroso de
medición y de reducción de pérdidas
que más bien las aumentó
se han otorgado
decenas de contratos de generación de
energía solar
térmica e hidroeléctrica
a precios onerosos y lesivos al interés
nacional
las pérdidas por robo inglés
alcanzan más del 38 por ciento
el impacto en el flujo de caja es de más
de 10 mil millones de lempiras anuales
450 millones de dólares
honduras supera con creces los
porcentajes promedios de pérdida en la
región
convirtieron
al estado en opresor y violador a los
derechos humanos
con el honduras open for business
falseando cifras
han puesto en entredicho la soberanía
popular
con el proyecto
de venta de territorios a las sedes
destruyeron a prontamente
a cuatro de los cinco magistrados de la
sala constitucional
para poder lograr este propósito
venden el territorio como cualquier otra
mercancía
en este acto
entrego al congreso nacional el proyecto
de decreto que deroga la ley de las
sedes
elaborado por la abogada y diputada
maribel espinoza
han
modelado toda la legislación a sus
propios intereses de grupo
sin importar el brutal daño sobre la
población
a la que la han reducido a la miseria
esta no fue la de la década perdida como
la de
sino la década corrompida en la historia
de honduras
es imposible
encontrar otro momento en nuestra
historia tan lleno de sabotaje contra
nuestra patria
pero no vine hoy
a elaborar un relato cargado de quejas
ni a deducir cuentas históricas del
pasado
eso
ya se encargará la justicia
[Aplausos]
cuando creamos el partido de la
resistencia
y formamos alianzas políticas lo hicimos
con una profunda conciencia ética
para refundar honduras
como una misión de patria
una misión
que no solamente
se llamará a cuentas
aquellos que han sido responsables de
que la imagen de nuestro país
ande por los suelos
sujetas al desprecio mundial
sino que estamos comprometidas con
nuestra propuesta del socialismo
democrático
a sentar las bases de combate frontal a
la corrupción
para que estos hechos
que nos han avergonzado
jamás
vuelvan a repetirse
la refundación de honduras
comienza por el restablecimiento al
respeto del ser humano
la inviolabilidad de la vida
la seguridad de los ciudadanos y de las
ciudadanas
los
escuadrones de la muerte
[Música]
ante los feminicidios
o
no al narcotráfico y crimen organizado
queremos
el hondureño y la hondureño
sienta la presencia de un estado
garantista de sus derechos
donde se pueda vivir en paz